guess how many's in there 18. you're
such a dork why why what how many are in
there
oh our years of marriage
so now do you know how many would be in
there nope how many years have we been
married are you serious
31 years 30.
they are amazing it wasn't what it was
it was the
oh it's no longer angry with her for
what had gone through in my life with
her
I was willing to see the error of my
ways
and then work to determine whether we
were good with each other anymore
wow and so my other three best friends I
expressed that
baby it's okay Mary and I can work it
out maybe you know I mean like I'm going
like that with these three women and it
just rattles Christine
do you know that there was an
anniversary where you made Rice Krispie
treats for every year that you guys were
married yeah and it was a simple token
yeah
there was a moment there where he was so
open to reconciling with you
because he felt that that was the moment
that he could put the past away and be
with you that's interesting that he felt
like that because that is also the same
day that he was like
um you know we went out on a picnic and
he was saying no you're supposed to have
been courting me I said Cody I've been
waiting for you he's like I'm not coming
I've been waiting for you honestly and
I'm not coming I know that after I
turned off my camera
I put my arms around him
up around his neck and I said what'd you
do if I just kissed you right now he was
physically
aboard
and he was backing up
he's like I can't do that
it makes me feel good that he was
considering it but it didn't last
through the evening I guess well I would
be open to it he kind of mentioned that
there was a family get-together and that
Christine found out about it and
Christine Bach did a Reconciliation and
that made him sort of reconsider
I I don't know what you're talking about
she bulk did a reconciliation with you
yeah me and Cody yeah
that she couldn't she doesn't want that
she couldn't deal with that
I never knew about that moment with him
and I never knew about the moment with
Christine until you just told me
[Music]